I really like typing so I was inquiring
about your keyboard earlier why are you
like typing because it's like the very
fast like really rapid response what's
the reaction time I like things that
like have very fast reaction times like
games like that
but typing is not a reaction or is it
the brain generating words and then
you're like cause typing a reaction okay
The Sensation that I get when I am
typing is the kind of thing that I'm
trying to point out so maybe maybe a
reaction time isn't the quite I don't
know what the term is but whatever that
thing is like the thing where you have
to like look at a word and then
communicate it into your fingers yeah
it feels like dancing like you're
responding you're responding to your
brain your fingers are doing the
responding to the brain they generate
the words
making your body do what your brain
wants it to do but like fast and
precisely well then you might not like
this Kinesis keyboard because it makes
the it makes it easier to do that you
probably like the struggle right no you
well I mean that it looks hard because
you have it looks like it's high
depression on the keys no it's well oh I
see yes more than more than like a
laptop keyboard but like
that you don't have to one of the the
main things is you don't have to move
your fingers at all So like um so like
for example a lot of people that I think
they have a backspace up in the top
right corner yeah so if you have to make
mistakes which is like
I mean that's like so metaphorical like
every mistake you have to like really
hurt yourself for because you have to
like stretch for the backspace
yeah no uh
yeah I don't and I see it as as a good
thing it's a good like a of romantic
element permeates my interpretation of
the world yes